so a little bit about me and we heard a
little tidbit I'll talk about in a
minute I have a relationship with like
almost all the speakers topics some
level I did genomics for 10 years after
my biostat PhD and then I got sick of it
simply because the way the field was
going was going in one direction I
didn't like the direction right now I
work at nîmes anyone here from NIH or
DHHS good so I don't have to give you
the test of what nyam says and I said 27
Institute's you're supposed to know the
acronyms for most of them this is the
earth writers group so obviously
Rheumatology I co-founded a startup
cause answers which we do sensors for
sleep apnea screening and a few other
things I'll talk about some of the work
I'm doing there today so NIH is north 15
miles answers is an Arlington his drug
right across the river
I'm a biostatistician but as I just
mentioned someone I actually don't do
clinical trials except as a reviewer so
I on a data safety monitoring board
member for mental health trials for the
NIH and I also am a reviewer for SBIR
trials in neurobiology so I've got I'm
all over the place so if my talk is
scattered you'll understand why I teach
practical R which is the name of the
course at the grad the NIH cut and
graduate school which is their basic art
class that's taught to all the graduate
students in the the bio trans data
science program most of you have met
Martin at some point he chooses the
basic Python class there so we serve
partners colleagues and arms there and
my personal interest in this area is
instable machine learning data
visualization which I'll talk about
today and how do we pass this knowledge
on efficiently to the next generation of
whatever you want to call yourself be
data scientist at station operations
researcher or whatnot
on the community side we've only
mentioned I've survived eight the grind
of the data community I was at the first
meetup in DC literally eight years ago
I'm a forum board number of data coming
to DC and somehow I know Jared mentioned
this earlier about books and meetups and
the like I actually managed to co-author
a book with some other people who were
in the community a few years ago
wouldn't be here with my family my so
this from Diwali like three days ago
literally my wife and daughters made the
rangoli which is on the floor
and so my I did my duty as a father and
a husband and just appreciated their
creativity because I have there's no way
I'm doing that my wife is not working on
her third master so she's far more
qualified than me and my both my
daughters are classically trained in
Indian dance and they're also on
advanced courses at their school so you
think there's a lot of song and dance at
home but it's nothing do with Bollywood
which is really nice my older one is
practicing to play Ursula in the Little
Mermaid this for spring so very
different kind of song
and speaking of Aikido we talk to her a
little bit this bit is the second
longest relationship I have after my
parents it's it predates my marriage and
it's the reason I maintain sanity I
stuck around long enough this is proof
that if you stick around long enough in
something you actually get somewhere
just like you know the bad person that
doesn't go away even though they keep
throwing him finally got afford to keep
leg but a few years ago I teach about 50
miles north of here in a place got a new
market for those really know Frederick
it's like the next town over if you've
never seen Aikido these are my friends
from Rochester and they're actually
husband and wife so this is how they get
rid of their marital angst they're
wonderful people they're also um
spits they actually make iron stuff so
this is if you've never seen keto and
the guy sitting standing in the back you
can see it much better on the screens
than on this screen which is a little
fuzzy that's my instructor from Japan in
this believe it or not he is 80 years
old in this picture he is now eating one
this from last year
he could still hit my button so it's
pretty interesting for a guy who's 122
pounds so that's what I do when I'm like
when it gets lofty
so regardless I'm gonna I actually
modify just add the slide after
listening to all the talks in this
meetup because it got me thinking so
someone was talking to you know Dave
Smith that he's started before are was
are I'm almost there I remember starting
in 1997 so it's been 20 years I think
point version point 3 so you know Roger
said yesterday version 0.6 he doesn't
have great hair yet you have to get
great here to get way back there but the
thing that I want to say about its is
that in those days we were dealing with
base our and base plotting and stuff
that people sort of don't use anymore in
some ways but it took a good 10 years of
working on there and developing that a
lot of the infrastructure came from s
plus before but cran was tiny cran was
in two digits right and then and then so
we did that for 10 years and then thank
God Hadley we can got a PhD and create
ggplot and then created plier and
created reshape and reshape 2 and D
plier and what's now become the tidy
verse and all the art studio supported
stuff that's out there now and that so
someone mentioning something about a
hockey stick shaped graph well have
leads the corner of that graph in my
opinion in terms of fire things happen
in terms of growth right but the nice
thing that's happened now and it's sort
of reflected in my talk and a lot of the
talks that have happened over the last
few days or last few hours essentially
uh last 48 hours is that ours become a
glue language in many ways for data
science so we've gotten the core parts
of are pretty well set right with tidy
verse and a lot of the packages that
know what they're doing and with
bioconductor which has been fantastic
for the biological sciences and genomics
and the all the omics stuff that those
of us were NIH are and by or in pharma
or in biotech used all the time which by
the way historically started up the
street as well at Hopkins so Ralph
Irizarry who was at Hopkins at time was
crucial in starting all of that so a lot
of stuff has happened here
but now it's become a glue language
right I mean today we're getting
wrappers around things that allow us to
ingest all sorts of data so heaven is a
package all the time to grab SAS data
there's XML there's all sorts of things
that Missy if there's data out there or
can ingest it now to the efforts of a
lot of people and on the backend of this
we've gotten to the point where we've
wrapped these JavaScript beautiful
JavaScript visualization libraries from
art through HTML widgets or other
platforms right so ours and not just
there if who here's tried out the ARS to
do a preview version the version 1.2
that's on the preview I know you're
using it so as am i if you go down the
list of so on the left corner when you
hit that plus button and said you know
our script or arm are down or text or
whatever the new version includes Python
SQL stand and there's some other
language that's in there as well so our
studio and ours becoming the glue
language reticulate who here's youth
particulate or those of the package
reticulate so particulate is a play on
Python right is another kind of path
Python or banana Conda and it connects
our to Python or Python to our there's
always been our PI 2 which connected our
to Python so the point is you don't have
to be a mono glut anymore in data
science you can actually interact early
use different things than our seems you
wanted the good glues around that so
great time to be in our and come to our
conference and use it because it's
really really rich now so what's
sticking around for 20 years like the
other stuff right now it's finally fun
there's been fun for a while actually so
what I'm going to talk about today I
mean I sorta have to talk about what I
put in my abstract some extent so the
answer is about five years old we've
been doing these sort of small passion
you see it in real time on a model in a
couple of slides this Bucky a big six on
your lip L sticks on your neck and the
primary purpose that we had of this was
to try and detect sleep apnea in a
comfortable situation
anyone who has ever taken a sleep study
polysomnography lucky you sleep sleep
apnea testing requires you to be
overnight in a hospital
with 16 leads on you including a chest
strap a head cap a cannula and all sorts
of wires so yeah you're getting real
great sleep on a sleep lab one of the
big problems we found talking with
people around this is that you have to
do is children sometimes and children
hate it especially the cannula so trying
to think of new ways so this is in
process the after this needs to deal
with FDA and stuff like that but what we
realize that we can actually leverage
this technology to work with activity
modeling activity monitoring through
breath work right - your breath rate is
about the heart rate and so when we went
there we realized we sort of have to
compare this and figure out sort of what
ground truth is and you know we had a
talk from NIST about talking about
ground truth and how to compare things
so there's not really ground truth show
unless you go to next areas lab and do
stuff and we've done some of that but
also just field testing right the
runners are enormously tech savvy right
- they're wired with Garmin's and
whatnot
today most a lot of us are wearing a
SmartWatch or a Fitbit or whatever so we
have sensors on us that collect activity
data and so when we talk about how you
can sort of grab grab at that and play
with it so the data I'm going to talk
about today is actually GPS data from a
Garmin Forerunner which one of our
crash-test dummies used on a few runs
and he also had an additional heart rate
strap so we've got heart rate through
that as well
now I hadn't played with this data
before so I went out and looked serve
the kind of stuff that Maura did and
Marge's talked about and I found out
that essentially you can get all this
data in something called GPX format
which is the GPS exchange format turns
out it's all it is is X is XML so it's
not rocket science
thankfully it's an open format that you
can check and there is the Dom is is
well known and you know how to do it and
so there are packages people have
written for this so in plot KML there is
a read GPX function in map tools is a
read GPS function but since this is just
an XML file I just I went bare MEDLINE
and use the XML package right and so
gory code we're not going to go through
the details of it but the point ends up
being that you can extract each of the
track that you would see
displayed on a GP on I'm like Strava or
runtastic or whatever your favorite
software is by grabbing essentially
those four lines we just grab out the
tagged data from the XML file so
reasonably easy so what we're trying to
do here so you can tell how small this
thing is it's literally on the guy's
lapel we're detecting breathing in
motion so there's an accelerometer in
here there's microphone and we distilled
the raw signals into respiration rates
and cadence which is how many times
you're stepping permit and you can
because of the SAR meter no I won't give
any details of how I do that
obvious reasons but I will talk about
how to sort of use that in sort of
create some visualizations with it so
we've seen a lot of leaflet this
conference right very easy so this is an
example of one run so I took the
longitude latitude from the GPS I'm just
plotted it and this person was going for
those of you know this area went sort of
from central Arlington crossed the river
and went to Dupont Circle
so but this is a leaflet is great but
we've got other tracks right so we're
not just dealing with where they went
we're talking about things like
elevation thinks about heart rate that
they have things the breathing rate that
we're picking up so sort of thinking
more in our so first of all just go to
ggplot plus sort of leveraging what mark
talked about yesterday and the pack
we'll the first thing I'm going to show
is GG map one of the ones that Mark
didn't talk about so Gigi map makes it
very easy to do maps it has so this is
off a Google map and you can tell it
there's different kinds of maps you can
do I this one is the map type is Road
map you can do a terrain map there's all
sorts of things you can do and then the
the syntax is very ggplot right the one
little twinkle that has happened the
last year is Google changed their policy
you now need an API key to actually get
the maps which means they want your
credit card right as some of you have
probably figured out who use maps Open
Street Map is an alternative but they
were more clergy in terms of this
connection for whatever reason
so yeah so I can make a nice static map
of this route I can even use things like
our plot or greater range or so there's
several packages in the ggplot extension
world that will create multiple
independent ggplot objects and put them
together right I tend to prefer cow plot
I have no idea why the man named it how
plot because it's a personal package
that he released his lab package he
released
it's really really nice and so what I'm
seeing here is the run on one side and
then the right side I'm seeing his heart
rate over time and then this is weird
dip right suspicious the first part I
get because he's starting his run from
static right but there's this weird dip
but the problem is I can't what the
static graphs connect these chill I
didn't know which part of the run this
happened in and so there's really really
nice too so Jared Reef Lee mentioned
cross talk at some point I know
so cross talk is this really nice
package that has been written to share
data across visualizations and not all
visualizations are crosstalk ready so
caveat emptor leaflet is and d3 scatter
is the one that you normally use for
this kind of data is diagraphs if you go
to the HTML widgets website and start
mining it diagraphs is the time series
one it's not crosstalk ready and I
actually went under github issues page
it's still after three years is still
not you crosstalk ready they're still
discussing it
so the d3 scatter worked pretty well and
so the idea here is actually very you
know elegant in some ways so at the very
beginning you create a shared data set
and then you share it with each of these
different visualizations and you arrange
it to this bs calls function and and so
you say it up in columns so it's very
very I find it very elegant to to work
with it the interesting thing with this
of course is the syntax that I see in
leaflet and III scatter reminds me of
Gigi vis with the tilde notation with
the one-sided formulas
yeah Jared's laughing because he
actually gave a
but Gigi visit remember it and it's dead
basically now it's dead in the water
not his talking not really but the
achieve is is that in the water but the
notation state I stuck around for some
reason so this reminded me of that at
the very bottom saying I have a filter
slider so the reason that crosstalk
works just two things well it is meant
to do what's called linked brushing so
if you have two pictures and you select
a part of it it'll all make its like the
part the corresponding points and the
other one which is great unless you have
a lot of points and you can't tell the
difference between what's selected and
what's not so I added the filter slider
to just kill a bunch of points when I
want to want to drill in and then I can
actually do a link brushing so that's
the that's the reason for that and
you'll see in a minute so that's why
that filter slider happened so these are
actually linked so now I have leaflet on
the left and I have the d3 scatter on
the right same data so you notice this
light should be live so if I actually
select that part it is selected but it's
not lightening enough on this side for
me to find out where that's being
selected right that's why I need the
filter so let's get out of that so this
is roughly at ten minutes into the run
so let's take this slider and go I'm
gonna bring you to abouts a little
earlier so let's go to eight minutes and
let's bring this side down to you want
to move with me today thank you please
pretty please
it doesn't like me today I'm sorry the
current feeding of sliders has not
happened I'm sorry
but but I know the answer so I'm going
to actually drill down to it so this is
at the very beginning of this and I've
actually seen where the drop is this is
at the beginning so both sides got cut
off right so if I move this slider back
a little you see that both graphs are
growing back out so if you bring it back
down to eight I'm at the beginning of
this drop so I'm way down here so let's
go in there move it up a little bit so
people can see and so if I just see
where this drop happened now this thing
will actually because I've fewer points
I can see exactly what happens this
little dark it's going to look much
better on the LCD is if you if you're
back there the drop happen because she
was waiting at a crosswalk for about two
minutes which is a really long crosswalk
stop but his heart rate fell but this is
part of the power of these linked
dynamic visualizations I can drill down
from the graph and go there's an
explanation here because this is weird
and so being able to find that is
actually really really nice I'm going to
add respiration to that panel so same
data set same structure except I'm doing
two panels one with respiration one with
heart rate and hopefully that will work
there we go
so as the same panel I just squished
them so the top one is heart grade the
bottom one is respiration and we saw and
the nice validation for us was that when
heart rate wind outside the respiration
so see the story so he his heart rate
went down he has to get back up to his
training levels so he works very hard to
get it up there really quickly so his
breathing goes up and then stabilizes
and then there's a little bit with
elevation here that I'm not showing
today which is fine and then there's
this really weird piece right here this
piece that I'm if it actually selects
it's likely on my screen but it's not
selecting very well there that piece
which was really weird so why are you
breathing so hard for in about five
minutes or reading that fast so same
deal let's go to minute 35 hopefully
this will slide over
because it seems to behave there we go
and then let's see if this left side
actually wants to move the right side
just doesn't want to move for me today
it's okay so what you realize is this
beginning of this was when he was
crossing the Key Bridge has anyone from
DC actually walked across the the Key
Bridge you realize how windy it is
that's what happened there the mic
didn't have a windscreen on it and so we
got a lot of noise on that screen and
that created an artifact we just wait
for this is actually one of our early
experiments that helped us figure stuff
out here but it's stuff like so this was
really part of what I was doing when I
was analyzing this because you can't
squint at the data per se you have to
really look at it and tools like this
were really really invaluable for it so
what would you notice so I have created
dashboards on nationally to you you can
create a shiny app it's all this fun
stuff that everyone is now doing if you
haven't used flash dashboard I'm
actually that's my new love affair
because it's really really nice and
there's actually really nice article as
to when you should use the Flex aspirant
use shiny I forget who roads might be
David or it might have been
Hadley well someone wrote it basically
flesh dashboard does not have a shiny
server underneath it so it's just native
JavaScript connections but it's really
nice or you can just have some fun so
there's another term nice package that
Thomas Peterson has updated recently
called GG animate which was originally a
David Robinson package and it's no
longer actually is really funny going on
to stack or on to Google because some
people have the old API the David wrote
and some people use the new API that
Thomas wrote and they don't tell you
which one they're using so suddenly so
you're going gg animate PN you realize
no no that's David that's not Thomas's
so it's very interesting so the buyer
beware when you're looking online for GG
animate advice
and so you can do literally with two
additional lines of code from what I've
did for my ggplot I can actually track
what you did so it's very very easy now
which is which is just sweet
so I'm actually on time so Jarrett can
can thank me later the presentation is
on github and I have a blog and stuff on
Nathalie flying you know following the
ewwy path of blog down and so on
I'd like to end with one thing is almost
for the end of the to the conference and
it's been a great conference I'd like to
ask for a round of applause for Jared
and Mark and all the lander crew who
have done a wonderful job and all the
sponsors I know there's only two left
but a great job guys hopefully we'll see
you again next year okay thank you very
much
[Applause]